hello and welcome to this video
yeah this is some a new kind of video
that I haven't done before like that but
I wanted to try this out and it's some
churches opening skewer name so your
questions answered yeah as best as I
possibly can without taking 20 hours to
prepare it I have to have to say so if
you got a question like okay what should
I play like here and give me give me a
full repertoire
yeah I won't I won't do that but I'm
able to without yeah doing 20 hour prep
to give some I think decent advice on
opening questions so if you have
questions about openings what to play or
whatever it's a wide range yeah message
me or absorb post a comment to to to
this video and I'll see what I can do in
future one so I need something to kick
off and I'm going to do that with a
question that was posted to the chess
section of Reddit yesterday and I
thought it is an interesting question
because it's a type of question that is
so quite often asked I haven't set this
up properly so that you can just read
the post I'm switching to reddit I'm
just telling you it's not a big text and
it's posted to him or the question is ad
for defense that dovetails with
Alekhine's defense
yeah the poster says he revamped his mic
repertoire and studied Alekhine's
defense what are suggestions for and
aesthetically thematically similar
response against deform alright so I'm
giving you some information what I think
and this kind of question is quite often
met like I like to play this and that
against efore what should I play against
D for is it something that is somewhat
similar or shares themes there are some
cases where openings indeed somewhat
similar in particular in regards to pawn
structure
and color complexes for example it's a
very well-known suggestion and
frequently seen that you can somehow
group the Slav and the caro-kann into a
repertoire so for example in the
classical Carole just playing this it's
not super critical to to to the whole
thing you see this pawn structure here
and this pawn structure with black
having swapped the D pawn against Ipoh
on or sometimes e pawn and then play a
66 is very typical for the Slav and for
the Kuro so this is something that
somehow fits well quite together or for
example let's say I'm against d4 you
play the Kings in Yin where you will
oftentimes get a close center like that
and then similarly against eform you
could build a repertoire I mean this is
obviously complex because what can do
all kinds of things but let's assume he
plays the Wii which is still most
frequently seen you could for example
play something like this which has a
definite resemblance there with f5
coming later so sometimes you have
shared pawn structures with openings
from d4 and e4 and some players indeed
choose their openings in that regard so
that the structures are similar there
are however players and very successful
players even with a very narrow opening
repertoire will play entirely different
structures yeah there are many examples
for that too the most striking one that
that comes to mind for me somebody you
might not really know all that well
there's a former Russian now for many
years Netherlands Dutch Grandmaster Sega
TV akov to flick off with black plays
against a foe always a Sicilian and
usually plays a dragon type of setup he
he dabbled a little bit with his cannon
but usually he plays a dragon
accelerated normal dragon and against
defy always we absolutely always plays
the nimzo-indian and the queen's indian
defense which is totally different it
has a chance no no common features
sometimes people choose along common
features sometimes they don't and for
some openings the issue is and this is
now that whereas we get to the actual
post is with the electrons it does not
have a particularly typical pawn
structure because after a 5 not the move
that you necessarily meet on the club
level and they often play ninety-three
them but if you look at the absolute
main continuations from here the palm
structures are quite are quite diverse
for example after c4 and here y takes
you can take with the C pawn you can
take with the e pawn which is entirely
different or if y place 90 or 3 it is a
huge range of things that black and you
can go g6 Bishop g4 it's not really a
very clear clearly defined structure
therefore the alkynes does not really
have something that is so clearly
similar let's say Slav and Carol I mean
there are differences there as well but
there are themes there and in the El
accounts there is no particularly clear
pawn structure that is defined so the
question is in this case what it exactly
attracts the author to the alkynes we
don't know exactly because he only
posted just a couple of sentences but
there are a couple of things I will that
come to mind with the other coins um you
play a slightly offbeat opening it's not
a total main line and very often the
white players will face that like once a
year tops sometimes less it depends on
how many games they play but it might be
that they never get it for two years
three years whatever at least in
classical chess if we talk about that so
it's a surprise
and nothing that why usually will have
big crab on also it is rather
provocative and oftentimes why players
don't really like to play against Ella
cards which makes relatively little
sense because it is generally rather
comfortable opening for white if you
know something but often people are know
it like okay it's playing that and I
have no prep and and so on it's it's one
of those annoyance openings and what is
definitely coming into mind if you play
the other kinds and like this opening
then you don't mind to have a space
disadvantage this is something that will
happen quite often if you look at this
black of course will attack the center
but he will be a little bit lacking
space so it's not a classical opening
where you put pawns in the center so if
we now transfer that to one deform what
would be similar hmm
again we don't have a clearly similar
pawn structure that we can go for
because elegance has no defined pawn
structure that comes to mind so what
could we do so I think if we search for
something that is somewhat similar in
terms of spirit in terms of attitude
let's say it should be not a mainline
probably not a symmetrical opening so
probably not one d5 yeah let's say and
we don't really have to care much about
giving the other side a little bit of
space because it seems that this is not
a cause for concern it's an important
factor you have to think about do you
want to give give them space or not it
is very likely that honor or absolutely
on a meta level yeah it is very likely
that black should play something with d5
against you for yeah if we I mean even
if you look at alpha zero or what it is
doing or Leela and they never play or
whatever something that allows a pawn to
d5 and there is probably some grain of
truth to that but this is not relevant
for human chess and impact particularly
not for chess that is not on the 2800
level so you can play lots of things
that are similar to the
in nature provocative and a little bit
offbeat that doesn't mind to have a
spaces advantage first one comes to
minus 96 this move is actually not that
terrible however it is I think less
sound than the Ellicott's
for one very clear reason this one is
not hanging so white is not actually
forced to push the pawn not that this is
a bad move pushing the pawn it's not a
bad move but he's not forced to do so
and he has more options and oftentimes
what black will have is some sort of
transposition into something that he
might not want to play this is however
still rather playable there is nothing
particularly terrible about it yeah you
can you can play that I mean why this
going to be a bit better with efore or
other sensible moves but I don't think
that this is something where you will
necessarily lose quickly or anything it
requires a bit of study as does the
other cards but it is seen as a playable
option many players will not play d5 but
rather develop yes Oneida 3 for example
and now we get to what I say well I said
he is not forced to push it now you have
to make a decision that I don't know
it's not so easy to make do you want to
do this I don't think you want a 95 here
looks odd and if you don't play d6 and
95 what do you play you probably play
this and then you're in some sort of Chi
Goren yeah
after c4 and so on so it has a it has
some it has some drawbacks but you have
to see that white players don't really
know anything there and it's not clear
that they know anything about the Chi
Goren either other thing that is
interesting is that after c4 c5 I think
is quite reasonable this is a very
reasonable opening actually because if
white pushes d5 which is very likely you
will get a very decent game with 97 to
g6 or maybe even inserting the check
this is totally fine so there are some
things that are completely okay for
black so it's not so terrible this is
one suggestion that was made in in
threat I wouldn't really play knight c6
against title players that can prepare
or only if I really invest lots of time
to patch some holes another suggestion
that was made was the Black Knights
tango which is which is indeed somewhat
similar to the Alekhine's in terms that
this Knight chase is possible it's
anything that in this reddit thread
somebody suggested that the Black
Knights tango would be a bad opening and
instead suggested the Ben Oni which I
found funny because a Benoni is very
likely just worse in the tango okay I
played the tango quite frequently in
tournament chess and I can say I don't
really think it is so bad one thing you
have to however take account of why does
not have to play d5 and most players
don't do this they play Knight f3 Knight
c3 and it is actually not a theory light
opening there are many things you have
to know in terms of move orders for
example after Knight f3 you probably go
is 6 and after Knight c3 all of a sudden
you play in nimzo-indian or after g3 you
go into a BOGO Indian and so on it's a
it is an interesting opening but it is
rather heavy on theory it's not
something that is so easily learned in a
quick session so these are the openings
based on quick knight c6 I think the
tango is sounder then knight c6 on move
1 but it's also it's more sophisticated
than you might think in particular if
you don't have much background in the
openings you my transpose and you for
example if you know the nihms oh and no
yeah let's say this line then adopting
the tango is not so
big deal yeah but if you don't know that
and you don't know the bow it's it's
lots of work so this these are the
nights is six early ninety six lines
that have have some resemblance to the
electrons so what else is there that you
can do that it's kind of non symmetrical
and and provocative and someone of
beaters
so what comes to mind am actually two
types of opening families one is the Ben
Oni type of opening so the mediate c-51
Knight f6 and c5 or Knight f6 6 and c5
they're all somewhat related this is
definitely not a bad choice because you
will always get a non symmetrical
position which is almost invariably true
also for the other kind so it's non
symmetrical it is somewhat fighting on
the other hand what you need to take
into account is that it's not an opening
that is so kind to you if you don't know
some critical lines for example if you
play this move order and you play a
modern Benoni if some money somebody
play's a four against you and you're out
of book now you were very likely lose
the game yeah because you're just
getting steamrolled in the center so
it's something where concrete knowledge
of some lines it's totally necessary
it's simply not possible to do without
otherwise somebody who was good with
dynamics or just know some lines will
just kill you so the modern benoni
is something that needs to be studied
quite thoroughly other be known is a
little bit lighter on theory for example
if you play c5 immediately and they go
d5 and now you play something like let's
say if I if yeah this is something that
you can play basically almost without
any theory here the idea is that you set
up this close center and later try to
play some kind of f5 or prepare b5 most
likely you won't manage of those breaks
if Y play as well but this is something
that tick some boxes at least yeah some
sort of clothes Benoni
similarly natured opening is this the
check benoni which is the same pawn
structure only differences white already
is on c4 which makes a difference an
advantage to this kind of opening is
that similar to the Ella coins white
players don't get it on the board often
there will not be familiar with details
and you might compensate
well my compensate some slight lack of
quality with more experience and
knowledge a good thing about this is
that this opening can be played almost
without any concrete lines in mind
because the nature of the position is so
closed yam on the error on the other
hand it's not very much confrontational
at the very beginning which is more what
the other coin is so this is a good non
symmetrical type of opening if you want
less Theory an interesting different non
symmetrical approach would be f5 the
Dutch and this is actually something
that I feel goes quite well with the
other cards it's provocative it's often
annoying to the white player I know many
players who there are the Dutch I don't
like that I'm not quite sure again why
exactly why they dislike the Dutch to
play against it but one thing is you
don't get it on on the board quite as
often as white and you maybe only have a
vague idea so I think the Dutch is not
not a bad idea to consider as a partner
opening to the other cards it's a no
ends value provocative it's fighting
it's non symmetrical it could it could
it could be a good a good partner a
partner opening what else is there
what is a non symmetrical I'm actually
not that much an opening that would I
think to some regard fit well is however
the Grune felt something I want to
mention it's kind of it's a scary
opening and some
to play because it has that reputation
of being super high theoretically
critical with many forced lines and
sharply and so on all right this is true
but it depends a lot on who your
opponent is let's say if you're an 1800
player and you play another 1800 the the
other guy won't know some fifteen lines
of sharp theory and checkmate you or
whatever I don't see that happening and
if you study the group felt it shares
some themes of the Ellicott's it's
something that we have to take in mind
take into account it gives why the
center yeah that you sorry
Center that you can attack and try to
undermine this is quite similar in fact
to the Ellicott's both openings belong
to that somewhat hyper moderns who will
let you give up the center temporarily
and then attack it so the green felt is
not something that is totally out of
them out of the question
and it's not an opening that is an HEC
popular on the sub professional level I
don't see that often if I I often watch
games below 2,000 back from teams of my
club or in junior competitions and the
goon felt is very rare it's very rare
people are scared I think of it to adapt
it with because it's so much theory yeah
it's not like easy but it's also not
something that you should be totally
scared of and it might be something that
you enjoy because it's it shares some
aspects in terms of giving up Center and
then the tech it is a counter-attacking
opening so maybe this is also something
that comes into consideration so it's
not something where this is this whole
question i mean it's not something where
I have a very clear answer yeah it's not
so easy one general advice that I can
that I can give is if you searching for
opening ideas and you have some some
sort of idea I could play that this idea
comes to your mind what I suggest is um
invest a bit of time you don't need to
invest like I don't know 50 hours yeah
but just some hours try to look at some
games that you can find of this opening
recent games played by master players
played by a specialist it helps if you
have a database or some tool available
and then after this rough study of a
couple of hours see how you fare in some
online games blitz chess repitch s and
just see how it works how it feels how
you adapt to the position if you feel
totally uncomfortable and score nothing
then discard the whole thing just
discard it don't really think much about
anymore if you feel it could work like
you feel well this the results are good
and so on then invest a little bit more
time do some sort of test runs and see
how it works it depends how much time
you have how long that test run might be
for example a couple of years ago I
thought about playing at the CARICOM and
I took a little bit more time I mean
also well it depends on how crazy you
are yeah I took like maybe 2025 hours to
get a basic idea about the Carll against
against good opponents and then I played
it in toward I think one or two hundred
blitz games and then check my results
and they were bad I found out that I
cannot play this well and I have lots of
problems and then I discarded the thing
with other openings in winning the
similar way of adapting it
it worked differently for a long time
for example I I played the Slav with
with a six let's line the chip and anko
and I did the same approach I studied
the basic lines and then I played in
blitz and I immediately scored very well
so I recognized ok this and opening
there
can play and I played it quite
successfully for for many years so this
is a good idea if you have some kind of
job concept in mind do some basic study
then tried a little bit out in in online
chess it doesn't hurt if you lose a
couple of games and you get some some
grasp if you like it or not let me just
think about this I did not prepare this
video at all as you probably probably
notice let me just think about if there
is some other opening that you could
play that it's similar somewhat similar
in terms of provocative nos now I'm not
really I mean within the Dutch I mean I
was kind of suggesting the Dutch within
the Dutch um you of course have to
choose the line yeah what to play if you
play
a stone wall or if you play a Leningrad
Dutch if you're coming from the ellic
I'm I would rather go form the Leningrad
and not form the stone wall so long it's
not too bad but the Leningrad is a
little bit more than Nemec and a little
bit more confrontational also my
experience is what players tell me they
given the choice they'd rather play
against a stone wall and against the
Leningrad so I would rather go for the
landing right here with with g6 then the
stone wall if you've never if you say
paired with the other kind in terms of
sharpness and being provocative I think
this is a better fit but just my brief
opinion with not without knowing the
specifics of this poster his abilities
or whatever so um just a little bit of a
video to discuss some opening ideas to
kick off this concept so if you have
questions about openings yeah post them
in this video and we'll go along from
there thanks a lot for watching I hope
you enjoyed it